let's go to the phones let's start today
with our caller from the 7/7 4 area code
any time at 7 7 4 it could be Pat's
friends it might just be someone from
Worcester County we never know but 7 7
for caller please announce yourself and
tell us what your name is your question
today as well hi David
you were close I'm calling you from good
old University of Massachusetts at
Amherst very nice and my name is Roy and
I have two questions one is slightly
more important than the other okay go
ahead
my first question goes as follows do you
think that American politics at any
point in our future will come back to
the actual idea of a marketplace of
ideas as opposed to the popularity
contest that has become now it is I
guess I do not believe that no no and my
second question is do you think that
there's any way that we can reform the
current system to try and push it
towards a more intellectual dialogue
about the actual policies themselves
such as I've read about thought
experiments such as blind or deaf
elections where you don't see or hear
the face of the voice of the politician
but only their policies base your ideas
solely on them I doubt that we would
ever see that and I don't know that I
would really push for that but I think
there's a couple different things that
we could do I mean to go to the first
question I'm kind of kidding about just
a flat no but I think that in order to
really get away from the type of
politics that we've been going in the
direction of we really need to start
teaching critical thinking at an early
age and by that I mean probably by
seventh grade there should be critical
thinking classes and certainly in high
school and it should be over these
should be requirements right now the
problem with that is that you have a
element of the of American politics that
knows that when you teach things like
critical thinking people move away from
religion they move towards science they
move away from the right they move
towards the left on so many different
issues so unfortunately the party that
because we have a party that benefits
from not thinking critically electoral
II they benefit it's going to be tough
because you've got to get around them in
order to start doing that
that's number one in terms of elections
I've heard a couple different proposals
one of those proposals is not this
totally blind thing you're talking about
where you never hear the voice or see
the face but just read policies and
statements at least and some
municipalities have done this
nonpartisan elections the the elected
the candidate doesn't declare a party
you don't the ballot doesn't list it you
run as an individual so ideally the idea
would be you learn about the policies of
the person but of course when you have a
two-party system and when the Republican
and Democratic parties are basically
controlling the election process and
funding these candidates I don't know
how you really get to that at the
national level do you have any other
ideas Pat for how we might push in the
direction that Roy is suggesting well
it's interesting because even hearing
someone's voice could lead people to be
influenced one way or another so for the
Nixon Kennedy debates people who
listened to it thought that Nixon won
and washed it thought that Kennedy won
because while Nixon sounded better
Kennedy just looked more presentable so
there's gonna be bias no matter what no
matter what and I guess the the counter
would be well if you only read the
statements then you eliminate that but
then no then there's probably going to
be some bias towards the candidate who
is able to speak most simply or
something like that I've had better
oratory skills yeah better writing
ability yeah so I don't know Roy I mean
it's it's kind of depressing when you
ask it this way because things aren't
looking good but those are a couple of
ideas okay thank you very much and you
should don't lecture at Amherst at some
point okay yeah I'll be there the day
after Thanksgiving I'm gonna be
lecturing there next so but anyway it's
just for a class so unless you're in the
class I shouldn't even say what it is
it's not really open but yeah I'll
announce that if I if I do thanks Roy I
very much appreciate the call